tenemos una expresión cuadrática aquí
que es x cuadrada menos 3 x menos 10 y
lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
factorizar lo como el producto de dos
binomios o dicho de otra forma
queremos expresar esta esta expresión
cuadrática como un binomio verdad x +
digamos un número que todavía no sabemos
cuál es x otro binomio que sería x + ve
muy bien entonces como siempre te invito
a que hagas una pausa para tratar de
descubrir quién tendría que ser ahí ve
para que nos dé la expresión que tenemos
del lado izquierdo muy bien así que
vamos a hacerlo juntos y lo que vamos a
hacer es multiplicar estos dos binomios
verdad y para ello pues será necesario
recordar cómo multiplicar binomios y
para eso hemos hecho varios vídeos aquí
en cana academy que puedes consultar si
no recuerdas muy bien cómo se hace esto
por si definitivamente no tienes ninguna
idea de cómo es que se multiplican los
polinomios muy bien pero bueno vamos a
hacer esto de aquí entonces vamos a
hacerlo con mucho cuidado primero
tendremos que hacer x por equis que nos
da x cuadrada y luego sin saltarnos
pasos vamos a hacer esto vamos a
multiplicar a por x muy bien tendremos a
por equis y luego sumamos por ejemplo x
por b verdad no es lo mismo que b por
equis
y finalmente tenemos el producto de a
con b entonces vamos a sumar a por b muy
bien ahí tenemos a por b y bueno por
supuesto si tú ya tienes mucha
experiencia en esto de multiplicar
polinomios podrías incluso haberse
saltado esta parte pero lo importante es
que podemos agrupar estos dos términos
verdad entonces vamos a tener aquí a más
b que multiplica x verdad tendremos a
más b que multiplica a x simplemente
digamos juntamos estos dos términos y
luego sumamos perdón vamos a ponerlo
todo con el mismo color que llevábamos
vamos a tener a por b muy bien ahí
tenemos ya una forma escrita de este
producto de dos binomios verdad pero
esto ahora nos es útil porque podemos
tener una idea de quién tiene que ser y
quién tiene que ser b así que vamos a
relacionarlo por ejemplo aquí tenemos
nuestro x cuadrada y aquí
x cuadrada por otro lado nosotros aquí
tenemos menos 3x y aquí tenemos a b x x
así que qué es lo que nos está diciendo
nos está diciendo que a si nosotros le
sumamos b si le sumamos b nos tiene que
dar igual a menos 3 por otro lado que es
lo que vamos a tener
tenemos que menos 10 nos debe dar igual
a a por b así que el producto a por b a
por b tiene que ser igual a menos 10 muy
bien tiene que ser menos 10 y en general
si queremos factorizar una expresión que
tiene un coeficiente principal 1 por
supuesto aquí no se ve verdad pero en
realidad está dado de forma implícita el
coeficiente aquí es 1 entonces si
tenemos este coeficiente principal igual
a 1 es decir en el término de x cuadrada
entonces tendremos que buscar dos
números tales que al sumarlos nos den
este coeficiente que acompaña al t
x verdad y que multiplicados nos den el
término constante muy bien así que aquí
podríamos por ejemplo primero observar
qué ocurre con el día es verdad
podríamos tratar de factorizar el 10
verdad el 10 lo podemos ver como 11 por
10 o también lo podemos ver como 2 por 5
y esto es bastante interesante verdad
porque como este término es negativo
quiere decir que el producto de a&b es
negativo es decir deben tener signos
contrarios y la suma es negativa
quiere decir que el más grande debe
tener el signo negativo verdad y aquí
podemos ver que menos 2 + 5 estrés así
que ya se va apareciendo a lo que
queremos verdad entonces por ejemplo si
consigue consideramos menos 10 podríamos
escribirlo como menos 2 por 5
2 x menos 5 verdad ahora si sumamos
menos 2 y 5 nos da 3 pero si sumamos 2 y
menos 5 nos da menos 3 así que estos dos
son los números que estamos buscando
verdad simplemente deberemos poner a
igualados por ejemplo y pondremos de
igual a menos 5
así que si reescribimos todo este
ejercicio tendremos lo siguiente x
cuadrada menos 3 x menos 10 será igual a
x +
a que nuestro caso es 2 muy bien será x
+ 2 que multiplica a x + menos 5 verdad
que simplemente lo podemos poner como
menos 5 muy bien ahí lo tenemos entonces
todo esto que hicimos fue con mucho
cuidado para saber de dónde viene este
este análisis digamos pero en el futuro
digamos si observamos luego luego que el
coeficiente principal es igual a 1
entonces sólo nos vamos a preguntar por
dos números que sumados nos den el
coeficiente que acompaña x y que
multiplicados nos dé el coeficiente
digamos o el término constante verdad
así que por ejemplo en este caso
diríamos que pues bueno tienen que ser
de signos opuestos para que al
multiplicarse nos dé algo negativo y
como al sumar se nos da algo negativo
pues entonces el número más grande debe
llevar el signo menos verdad y entonces
uno dice bueno puede ser 2 y 5 nos da 10
el signo menos debe ir con el 5 entonces
sería menos 5 + 2 y en efecto nos da
menos 3 verdad entonces aquí dos y menos
cinco cumplen todo lo que queremos